[Musik]
heinz strunk ist der chronist
norddeutscher mittelalter meist eher
unansehnlicher männer in seinem
autobiografischen debüt fleisch ist mein
gemüse heißt es erzählt er seine
landjugend mit musik so lautet der
untertitel als saxophonist einer
ziemlich mittelmäßigen tanzkapelle auf
hochzeiten und schützenfesten in der
goldenen handschuh zeichnet er die
geschichte des frauenmörders fritz honka
nach der anfang der 70er jahre vier
prostituierte umbrachte die er zuvor in
kneipen auf st pauli kennengelernt hat
ich habe das taschenbuch exemplar hier
und hinten drauf schreibt ein gewisser
tobias rüther zitat tod trauriges leben
in sofort unglück ein großartiges buch
und genau deshalb liebe hörerinnen und
hörer haben wir uns gedacht wir laden
jetzt diesen tobias rüther literaturchef
der sonntagszeitung in unseren podcast
ein denn ein sturm hat ein neues buch
veröffentlicht das heißt es ist immer so
schön mit dir und trägt den untertitel
eine katastrophale liebe dass es damit
auf sich hat und was dieser heinz strunk
eigentlich überhaupt für ein autor ist
darüber weil wir heute reden
anschließend antwortet die
schriftstellerin daniela krien auf drei
unserer fragen über ihr schreiben und
lesen aber erst einmal willkommen tobias
rüther hallo hallo topi fangen wir mal
beim neuen roman an was ist das für ein
buch dieses es ist immer so schön mit
dir und ganz subjektiv gefragt wie hat
es dir eigentlich gefallen
der neue roman von heinz strunk ist eine
liebesgeschichte eine katastrophale
liebesgeschichte so steht es im
untertitel
so weit muss man vielleicht gar nicht
gehen seine gescheiterte
liebesgeschichte zwischen einem mittel
alten mann der eine gescheiterte
wiederum gescheiterte musiker karriere
hinter sich hat und jetzt einen job
macht indem er sich nicht so richtig
erfüllt fühlt mit einer frau zusammen
ist die heißt julia mit der sich auch
nicht richtig erfüllt fühlt und der
eines tages bei einem empfang eine
befindet bildhübsche schauspielerin
kennen lernt mit der er obwohl er das
gefühl hat dass sie mindestens drei oder
vier liegen über ihm spielt dann
tatsächlich eine liebesbeziehung beginnt
die dann über den verlauf der geschichte
obwohl die beiden sich sogar verloben
und cool also tatsächlich drauf und dran
sind zu heiraten und sie eben
titelgebend sagt es ist immer so schön
mit dir dann endet das aber dennoch eben
im nichts und der mann dessen namen wir
nicht erfahren beginnt wieder genau dort
wo er aufgehört hat oder immer wieder
neu anfangen muss nämlich in mit seiner
eigenen mittelmäßigkeit unter der stark
leidet das ist so die die geschichte und
wenn ich jetzt direkt so damit
einsteigen muss wie ich es finde ich
habe eines stroms karriere als
schriftsteller auch als komiker schon im
grunde von anfang an verfolgt und bin
immer bin immer ein großer fan gewesen
vor allen dingen von seinem
humoristischen von humoristischen
anteilen seines werkes ich bin mit
diesen neuen roman nicht so richtig
einverstanden weil ich das gefühl habe
dass er hier was ich toll finde etwas
neues für ihn neues probiert hat nämlich
eine liebesgeschichte zu erzählen
dass aber die anteile die er quasi so
als default modus immer in seinen
büchern unterbringt sprachkritik
gegenwart kritik leiden an sich selbst
leiden an der welt dass die immer wieder
quasi sich in diese liebesgeschichte
hineinarbeiten effekt mäßig und dass
beide teile nicht so richtig aufgehen so
dass man im grunde so beides hat
und ich damit nicht glücklich wurde weil
ich es entschieden besser gefunden hätte
also entweder das eine zu tun also eine
absurde scheitern der liebesgeschichte
mit stroms instrumentarium der
gegenwarts beschreibung sozusagen oder
eben eine liebesgeschichte die
unglücklich ausgeht also ich habe
gemischte gefühle
jetzt hat sich heinz strunk hier
eigentlich schon länger so von seinem
ursprung als komödiant oder mit
komischer schriftsteller weg entwickelt
und weg geschrieben also hat er
angefangen mit fleisch ist mein gemüse
hat auch lange eine titanic kolumne
gehabt und dabei eigentlich spätestens
mit dem mit dem goldenen handschuh ist
dass hier tatsächlich muss man sagen ist
das so literatur im wirklich im
eigentlichen für die touristischen sinn
also komisch ist an dem buch ja
eigentlich nichts mehr sondern sie ist
eher im gegenteil sehr drastisch und
auch ziemlich trostlos warum hat er
jetzt mit diesem genre mit dem
beziehungs roman mit dem liebesroman so
ein problem
ich weiß nicht ob das also das kann ich
das ist jetzt erst mal eine schwierige
frage ob die zu beurteilen warum er
dieses problem hat ich glaube es ist
seine die entscheidung vielleicht
einfach noch nicht richtig aufgegangen
dass das was er über verschiedene bücher
die glaube ich von anfang an literatur
gewesen sind also es hat natürlich
diesen ritterschlag des handbuchs
gegeben wo dann im grunde dann die
komplette literarische republik
festgestellt hat dass dieser mann
wirklich ein hochbegabter schriftsteller
ist ich glaube dass die anderen sachen
davor auch schon literatur waren und er
hat halt einfach jetzt eben in so einer
gewissen konsequenz das nächste thema
sich vorgenommen in diesem fall eben
einen liebesroman ich glaube auch dass
er da in diesem sinne sehr ehrgeizig ist
sich verschiedene formate vorzuknöpfen
ich glaube aber dass er hier dass ihm
hier etwas im weg steht was einfach
immer noch der grössere effekt
nämlich sich hinein zu finden in diese
mittelmäßigen an den eigenen ambitionen
leidenden typen die gleichzeitig nicht
nur an sich selbst und ihrem körperbild
leiden sondern eben auch daran wie in
der gegenwart über die gegenwart geredet
wird der ist einfach hoch empfindlich
wie alle strunks strunk männer in allen
büchern davor
und ich habe das gefühl also wenn es das
problem gibt dann ist das das in dieser
man doch mehr interessiert als die
liebesgeschichte und die frau um die es
geht die relativ konturenlos bleibt die
zwar eine dramatische
hintergrundgeschichte bekommt aber so
richtig interessiert er sich als
erzähler dann doch wieder für diese
figur und da sind die ähnlichkeiten zu
den männerfiguren vorher schon so groß
dass ich das gefühl hatte er das ist
sozusagen es das ist so ein
ungleichgewicht zwischen einem großen
schritt den er machen wollte die dann
zögerlich gegangen ist und einem
routinierten erzählen eines mit alten
mannes wo ich das gefühl hatte ja
tatsächlich das kann er sehr gut aber im
interesse seines eigenen projektes ist
das nicht bringt einen das nicht voran
es kann aber ja auch sowas serielles
haben eigentlich es kann ja auch sein
dass er sozusagen dieses diese eine
figur porträtieren möchte in
unterschiedlichen spiegeln in
unterschiedlichen kontexten und dass
gerade so ein geschäft zu einer in der
eigenen fantasie eigentlich
unerreichbaren figuren die man sich
verliebt dann guter anlass ist die in
porträts ein weiteres hinzuzufügen mit
gewinn also das für mich wäre das noch
kein zwingendes argument für ein
problematisches oder gescheitert ich
würde auch nicht so wenn also wenn ich
jetzt ich darauf antworten sollen ich
würde auch nicht sagen dass das
gescheitert ist ja glaube es ist es
sowas was so in auf der hälfte auf der
hälfte interessant stecken geblieben ist
und ich finde aber was du sagst
natürlich sofort total interessant
dieses serielle herstellen von
männerfiguren
die eben nicht also ich habe jetzt als
vorbereitung für diesen podcast noch mal
drüber nachgedacht was eigentlich das
spezifische an diesen männer
beschreibung es und es ist jetzt eben
nicht so dass hier ein viriler typ wie
man das eben auch aus anderen romanen
und von anderen roman schriftstellern
vor allen dingen kennt das ja ein so ein
geiler typ der eben aufgrund seiner
eigenen schlauheit an der dummheit der
welt leidet und allen seinen willen und
auch dank seines grandiosen intrexx
aufzwingen kann so eine figur ist das
nicht sondern es ist abermals jemand der
zwischen seinen eigenen ambitionen
zwischen seinem taxieren den blick auf
sich selbst und dem eingebildeten
taxieren den weg blickt der restlichen
welt zwischen den problemen die sich
irgendwie sich und seinem körper hat und
den ansprüchen der hat wir leben sollte
dass die stranden diese figuren stranden
regelmäßig und sie sind eindeutig nicht
maskulin in dem sinne wie man jetzt
sagen würde das sind somit typen oder so
sondern die belästigen die sind die
plastic möglicherweise sich selbst mit
ihren eigenen ambitionen die nicht
aufgehen und lange rede jetzt kurz adh
moderation
ich finde das interessant und weiter
emanzipatorisch oder sagen wir innovativ
diese figur weiter und weiter zu
schreiben weil ich kaum einen zweiten
kerner der sie so schreiben kann
dahinter verblasst aber dann das
eigentliche dieser liebesgeschichte weil
die frau einfach dazu zu hingetupft
wirkt finde ich und dann hat so ein
ungleichgewicht mit dem ich eben nicht
glücklich war ich habe sehr viel meinung
zu dieser frauenfigur
um ehrlich zu sein diese vanessa heißt
sie glaube ich dieser vanessa ist ja
schauspielerin ist sehr empfindsam hat
immer so ein bisschen ist ein bisschen
problematisch und er empfindet sie sehr
oft als als irgendwie auch störend in
seiner welt also sie tut was und er hat
so eine schwester
die ganz schrecklichen phrasen redet in
einer ganz ganz grauenvollen familien
treffen szene die irgendwie dann so dass
das ende der beziehung einleiteten
eigentlich so da müssen wir vielleicht
noch mal hinkommen weil da geht es dann
nämlich mit der sprachkritik weiter das
zeigt dass ab und dass das ganze
problematische dieser figur und diese
ganze komplex komplexität dieser vanessa
die lässt sich eigentlich zurückführen
auf ihre hintergrundgeschichte die eben
eine misshandlungs geschichte ist weil
sie während ihrem
konfirmationsunterricht von diesen
jahres der denn da abgehalten hat der
glaube dekan ist der sie als junges
mädchen verführt fallen lässt und man
muss sagen also wirklich schlimm
missbraucht und ehrlich gesagt ist das
immer so eigentlich das faulste was man
machen kann dass man einer weiblichen
figur eine missbrauchsgeschichte
andichtet und dann ist sie damit sofort
irgendwie markiert als das macht sie aus
und deswegen ist sie kompliziert und
deswegen ist sie irgendwie irrational
und deswegen ist es immer manchmal
komisch mit ihr und das kommt mir halt
wirklich wieso eine etwas faule
abkürzung vor dass das dass diese das
ohne uhr szenen immer so eine komplette
frauenfigur aus machen soll und man sich
dann damit als männlicher autor ganz
viel charakter und ganz viel drumherum
und ganz viele widersprüche und ganz
viele facetten sparen kann
weil sie wurde ja missbraucht deswegen
ist sie komisch und ich weiß nicht wie
ihr als als männer das sieht aber mich
berührt das immer auf eine seltsame art
und weise weil das so eine art der finde
ich unredlichen reduktion ist
ich frage mich sofort warum ist dieses
ich frag mich sofort warum ist diese
szene eigentlich braucht also warum in
einer wie gesagt hingetupften die tour
dann auf einmal eine
eine ein biografischer aspekt vorkommt
also ob man es man hätte ja auch sagen
kann man dann belässt es bei diesem
skizzenhaften weil es vielleicht in
diese frau dann auch wirklich nicht geht
in diesem in diesem buch oder in der in
dem schreibt vorhaben von einem strom
aber das ist dann eben so was quasi
anekdotisches geben muss um ganz viel zu
erklären und ganz viel erklärung auch zu
ersparen oder abzukürzen
das finde ich unabhängig von dem was
dann erzählt wird schon ein schwieriges
verfahren also man um es vielleicht in
eine andere richtung zu bewegen
ich habe er das gefühl dass das also
alles das was sie gerade jetzt gesagt
habe leuchtet mir ein in der tat ist
auch die die das erfinden einer einer
dramatischen geschichte zur motivation
von komplexität im fortgeschrittenen
alter sagen wir mal ein bisschen ein
einfacher trick so das ist jetzt sehr
rabiat gesagt aber ja aber man könnte
auch also runde das jetzt also ich bin
hier nicht als als der anwalt dieses
romans möchte mich also würde ich mich
jetzt gar nicht äußern wollen aber ich
finde wenn man mal das so sieht man
könnte auch sagen dass das also es ist
ja so da kommt diese vanessa wie ein
also wie ein wie ein wesen aus einer
anderen liga in sein leben rein und mit
dem und es kann es nicht fassen auch
wenn es ein bisschen seltsam an läuft
auf einmal sind sie ein paar eigentlich
könnte alles einfach sein und in
trotzdem in dem sich in dieser sekunde
und da ist auch die
hintergrundgeschichte oder ob sie ihn
nervt oder so fertig zwei tage nicht in
dem augenblick wo sie ein paar werden
fängt er schon an und/oder beginnt es
schon ihn zu langweilen wird es schon zu
wenig wo ich dann sagen würde man könnte
auch sagen im grunde ist die frau
vollkommen austauschbar und einfach dann
in dem sinne auch ganz gleichgültig weil
sein leben offensichtlich nicht ist dass
selbst die schönste dass das dass er die
schuld dass er quasi die erfüllung in
der schönsten frau die er sich je
vorstellen konnte findet sondern
dass das einfach nicht die antwort auf
seine frage seine lebens frage ist und
dass deswegen er möglicherweise auch so
desinteressiert und so brüsk und so
genervt von ihr ist weil einfach ist das
offensichtlich nicht das problem ist das
klingt jetzt so ein bisschen nach
therapeuten jargon und so aber es könnte
der grund dafür sein warum sie dann also
es könnte auf jeden fall der grund dafür
sein warum er sofort eben quasi genervt
von iris obwohl sie die traumfrau ist
für ihn
es könnte aber auch erklären wir haben
sie so distanziert beschrieben wird und
im grunde eigentlich austauschbar wirkt
also um so könnte man es deuten das
würde dann quasi diesen das diesen
problemen noch verstärken in seiner
problem heftigkeit die strohmänner haben
ja immer sehr viel auszusetzen also sind
ja meistens so ein bisschen die grantler
und leute sprechen komisch leute wollen
schlimme dinge dann ist er ja mit
vanessa noch mal im urlaub in so einem
ganz schlimmen strandhotel und das sind
natürlich auch alle leute immer
furchtbar die ganze zeit was ich auch
ein bisschen nachvollziehen kann ehrlich
gesagt
aber jetzt mal vom negativen weg was
wollen sie denn was wäre denn die
erfüllung ich also wenn ich jetzt also
zeige ich antworte jetzt als eine
störungsfreie figur dass das müll gerede
aufhört das ist das snack snackbar gast
rohstoffe bistro gelaber der gegenwart
aufhört dass man nicht mit fitness
getränken gefoltert wird dass es keine
lied dienst mehr gibt das ist quasi
dieses ganze furchtbare mittelmäßige des
gut vermarkteten alltags dass das
einfach aufhört so zu sagen ich glaube
das ist das was und dass die leute halt
einfach nicht mehr so 0 zeug von sich
geben ich glaube das ist das was diese
figuren wollen und lustig ist wenn man
jetzt so tief in die tiefe reingreifen
die literaturgeschichte heinz strunk ist
ja ein großer großer leser von botho
strauß und hat auch einen sammelband mit
botho strauß texten mal für rohr
ausgegeben das ist natürlich auch eine
literarische tradition da muss man
könnte auch noch mal ganz andere leute
leute nehmen dazu da steht er schon
einfach quasi auch in der literarischen
tradition von einfach vollkommen gequält
seien davon dass es andere menschen gibt
die dümmer sind aber ich glaube dass das
also zu sagen wenn es nur darum gehen
würde es geht bei ihm aber nicht nur um
intellekt sondern halt einfach auch um
eine gewisse würde glaube ich gegenüber
der gegenwart und wie man sich verhält
wie man als mann auch möglicherweise
sich anzieht und so es ist komplexer
glaube ich als zu sagen der das ist
verachtung ich glaube es ist auch ein
tiefes leiden an daran dass die welt so
unglaublich mittelmäßig ist also
eigentlich auch so ein bisschen eine
schönheits suche oder naja das ist eine
interessante ja interessante frage
das ist eine wirklich ich glaube diese
frage wenn man über strunk redet redet
man immer so wie ich jetzt auch im
grunde schon 20 minuten tour von diesen
leidenden wesen die eben halt einfach an
der hässlichkeit der welt leiden
es könnte natürlich einfach auch die
verzweifelte suche nach irgendetwas was
still und würde voll schön es im leben
sein die eine suche die immer enttäuscht
interessante frage andreas also es ist
tatsächlich nämlich soweit auch jetzt
ich habe jetzt auch ein paar rezensionen
schon gelesen zum neuen buch da wird auf
einmal dann das finde ich auch ganz
unglücklich dass honka buch quasi als
maßstab der jetzt folgenden werke von
strom genommen
das funktioniert natürlich überhaupt
nicht weil es stank glaube ich immer so
raus ragt in eine andere richtung weil
es tatsächlich auch nicht projekt von
dem war aber die frage was eigentlich im
innersten dieses werk und ich würde ich
jetzt echt schon mittlerweile von dem
werk natürlich sprechen weil strom
übungen zusammen dass das auch die suche
nach schönheit und die unerreichbarkeit
von schönheit sein könnte das ist finde
ich jetzt erstmal einen einen innovativ
einfach innovativer als immer wieder
runter zu bieten was ich eben selber
tatsächlich getan habe
dieses leiden an werbe und marketing und
werbe vorzieht rock das kann man ja
selber auch als büro pauli schon kaum
mehr lesen
ja weil das leiden an impliziert ja auch
eigentlich etwas eine utopie dies die
dagegen stehen müsste theoretisch und
ich frage mich halt immer so ein
bisschen wo ist die vielleicht scheint
sie dann auch in fleisch ist mein gemüse
irgendwie schon
wo dieser junge mann mit seinem saxophon
halt in der musik aufgeht und wenn es
halt nur diese grauenvollen
schützenfeste und hochzeiten und sowas
sind aber es gibt da immer wieder so
momente wo er in seiner musik wirklich
aufgeht und das ist ja das was ihm
wirklich was bedeutet so und ich glaube
diese diese kleinen momente gibt es
immer wieder
jetzt nicht im handbuch da eben nicht
bei ihnen gerade gar nicht aber ich
glaube wenn man im rest sucht dann schon
mir fällt da gerade ein das ist jetzt
nicht strom als schriftsteller sondern
strom als musiker dass er ja auch eine
zeit lang mit blumenfeld aufgetreten ist
und das saxophon solo bei graue wolken
gespielt hat und kam dann auf die bühne
immer für diesen für diesen augenblick
und das ist eine relativ einfache kleine
melodie und in der tat also saxophonsolo
im pop musik hat natürlich auch einen
gewissen ruf aber dennoch
dann ist der ganze song hat ja auch das
liegt natürlich auch an distelmeyer den
geschrieben hat aber hat so ein jochen
distelmeyer hat einfach so eine einfache
klarheit und dann kommt strom und spielt
dieses solo und ich glaube dass das die
dass das was eben was ich hiermit würde
meinte dass es da eine einmal sind die
dinge geklärt und klar und stehen für
sich selbst einmal sind sie eine reine
emotion die nicht eben quasi vermittelt
vermarktet durch gespräche durch
neusprech irgendwie verhunzt ist sondern
es ist der reine klare ton
das ist eine sehr romantische
vorstellung natürlich irgendwie von
kunst gekommen
aber ich glaube wir sind jetzt
tatsächlich irgendwie jetzt hier was auf
da also das ist natürlich etwas was was
man bei hand strom jetzt erstmal nicht
vermuten würde und das würde dann
tatsächlich hier diesem buch nach meiner
einen aspekt ab bringen der dann weniger
mitarbeiter da würde ich darauf beharren
die also das würde den dass die
frauenfiguren diese beziehung
das ist quasi da nur so vordergründig
irgendwie so ins installiert quasi es
geht im grunde um eine andere frage und
ich da würde ich immer noch sagen ich
weiß nicht ob er dieser habe an der
beantwortung dieser fragen mit dem roman
weitergekommen ist als beispielsweise in
dem buch wie junge rettet freund aus
teich wo ich das gefühl habe diese das
ist zwar auch wieder so eine
sommerkinder geschichte so
effekten teufel aber wo quasi die
stimmigkeit von von atmosphäre von von
innerer von inneren vorgängen der
figuren liebe eigenartige liebe zwischen
einem enkel und seiner großmutter ganz
einsam in summe haus da waren ja daran
glaube ich an so einem an seiner
stimmigkeit die hier glaube ich eher
nicht erreicht das stimmt dass es so ein
ganz melancholisches buch und wo es eben
auch um freundschaft geht das eben auch
also freundschaft ist auch wieder sowas
und kompromittierte was ich was auch
irgendwie sich nicht wirklich
also ich glaube ich glaube freundschaft
ist für ihn auch irgendwie ein
ehrlicheres und und und von der moderne
weniger vermarktetes gefühl als
vielleicht liebe die ja immer so
aufgebauscht wird und vielleicht das
denn wenn wir noch mal auf diese
schönheit zu bekommen dann gibt es damit
der zwei probleme das eine ist dass es
eine bereitschaft zur zum zur
fokussierung braucht das heißt also man
muss sich wenn man sich für schönheit
interessiert auch entscheiden bestimmte
dinge auszublenden
und wenn man sprach empfindlich ist
beispielsweise oder störgeräusche
empfindlich oder empfindlich dafür dass
irgendwie neben den drei wunderschönen
rosenblüten noch eine welke im bild ist
oder sowas dann wird es schwierig mit
der schönheit um das andere ist eben
auch dass so eine figur dann feststellen
kann dass sie in einem schönen bild
eigentlich derjenige oder dasjenige
element ist was stört und damit ist die
schönheit wieder
aber das spielt ja dann auch und das
würde ja aber auch abermals bedeuten
dass man das ist um diesen typen und
nicht um diese liebesbeziehung geht
sondern was dem mit dem typen airbus es
also und dessen war mit wahrnehmungs
apparaten
ja ja ich also ich habe den eindruck
dass das buch ist von vielen sehr sehr
sehr sehr positiv aufgenommen worden
eben auch in dem sinne dass das ein
schritt ist und ein anderes format und
so weiter und ich glaube auch das was
frisch auf was gerade das er gerade sagt
das ist einfach auch tatsächlich eben
ein komplettes sind auch komplexe
elemente da drin und so ich habe das
gefühl dass die das soll jetzt nicht
das soll jetzt nicht banal klingen aber
die es gibt halt in diesem grund dafür
ist die passage die eben andrea am
anfang erwähnt hat auch ganz typisch
wurde anhalt quasi wieder so quasi im
stakkato diese szene eben auf der grund
auf der auf den geburtstag der mutter
von vanessa wo eben quasi sich so dass
ein battle ergibt zwischen ein dummer
motivation spruch folgt dem anderen wo
quasi eigentlich eher so eine sonne
stand up oder so eine bühnenshow quasi
aufgeführt wird die eben vollkommen
unverbunden glaube ich bleibt mit dem
rest des romans und dann diese roma
diese stellen sind viel präsenter als
jetzt das was richtig was du eben gerade
beschrieben hast wo es einfach subtiler
wohl wo sozusagen so tina das
ausgestaltet werden muss und da werde
ich also wir haben zum beispiel ist auch
überhaupt nicht geredet ich würde sagen
gelungen ist das verhältnis dargestellt
zwischen zwischen dem erzähler und
seiner ex freundin julia die dann wo es
dann noch mal so ein rache sex gibt von
ihr und sie versucht ihn zu demütigung
demütigen er sie einerseits eben auch
wirklich richtig schlecht behandelt und
aber da gibt es quasi so eine konkurrenz
die funktioniert weil beide sogleich auf
an aneinander scheitern das ist ein
vielstimmiges bild glaube ich ohne jetzt
um nochmal jetzt ein anderes mache ich
ein komplett anderes fass hierauf aber
ich glaube da ist das verhältnis besser
irgendwie zwischen zwischen den beiden
figuren ja das glaube ich auch und ich
habe auch immer so ein bisschen also bei
heinz strunk und frauenfiguren das ist
glaube ich noch mal rechts und kapitel
also wir haben großartige mutter und wir
haben großartige großmutter wie in
junger freund teich
wir haben wahnsinnig abgewrackte
gestalten in goldenen handschuh die aber
auch irgendwie ein herz haben und denen
man auch irgendwie nahe kommt ich glaube
das problem ist wirklich die
begehrenswerte frau also die der mann
ein interesse hat und dass dieses
interesse ist meistens ein doch recht
oberflächliches also sie ist hübsch sie
es irgendwie ganz lieb und kann mit ihr
irgendwie nett am meer sitzen aber dann
tiefe reinzukriegen das ist glaube ich
tatsächlich für strom nicht so ganz
einfach
hab also völlig ins unreine gedacht aber
mir kommt das tatsächlich so vor dass
das das eigentlich dass die
begehrenswerten frauen eigentlich immer
die flachsten sind friedrich auf das
musst du jetzt beantworten
das muss ich jetzt beantworten völliger
unkenntnis des weiteren werks von heinz
strunk ich ja ich muss jetzt auch
diesmal im kopf durch die figuren sind
sind ja sind also karikaturen wäre jetzt
ein dass es hat so etwas werten das aber
es sind tatsächlich eben eher so vor
gefertigte figuren die quasi ja für eine
bestimmte konzentration an gefühlen oder
und projekt also eine projektionsfläche
würde man vermutlich ganz ganz banal
sagen das stimmt schon
ich glaube aber darauf würde ich dann
tatsächlich eben auch so würde ich immer
auch das dann zurück da würde ich immer
sozusagen mich davor stellen und sagen
ich glaube es geht auch wirklich gar
nicht darum diese frauen diese frauen
eben überhaupt wirklich mit leben zu
füllen sondern es geht um die effekte
und die probleme dieser typen und
deswegen man könnte jetzt natürlich
sagen in einer idealen in einem idealen
roman ist das aufgewogen quasi das da
oben ja die ganze zeit
ich glaube aber und da würde ich
wirklich darauf beharren dass die das
dass die typen aus deren augen wir ja
auf diese auf diese karikaturen schauen
dass die typen in ihrer in ihrer
hochfahrenden mittelmäßigkeit in diesem
diesem ich habe doch ambitionen
eigentlich müsste doch die geschuldet
die welt doch viel viel viel mehr als
sie mir gibt und als sie und wenn sie
mir die gibt reicht es immer noch nicht
ich glaube dass das die dass das
eigentlich das interesse an strom ist
und da will ich sagen können wir gerne
durch also das ging jetzt ich wollte das
gar nicht auf 60 klingen aber da können
wir gerne durch die literatur
literarischen figuren der letzten 20
jahren jeden wurst vergleichbare männer
gibt die so offensichtlich einfach
wirklich an also die einfach der hat die
schief zu sich selbst stehen zur feld
stehen diese so präzise leiden also dass
wir da finde ich das finde ich wirklich
innovativ aber es ist in der tat so das
ist wenn man so will ist das ein sprung
dann so ein bisschen so wie für die
braut großer name aber so ein männer
schriftsteller von so typen die immer
wieder die gleichen probleme haben und
wann und immer wieder muss man sich
genau anschauen und gucken woran liegt
ist und dadurch aber ein reh das
vollkommen recht ist das interesse also
dass die das interesse an den
frauenfiguren diesen roman druck dann
immer weiter in den hintergrund und so
ich glaube er hat es diesmal wirklich
das würde ich jetzt doch sagen das spürt
es ja er hat versucht es mehr zu machen
aber da kommt das andere interesse ist
einfach viel viel größer waren auch
unsere und dadurch kommt sie solche
schieflage die schieflage kommt
vielleicht auch dadurch dass eben dieses
missbrauchs kapitel ein besonderes
gewicht bekommt dadurch dass es so nah
an vanessa erzählt
es ist ja wirklich sehr personaler
erzähler und ganz ganz nah aus was wenn
es aussicht im gegensatz zum ganzen rest
vom buch das das restliche buch ist
komplett aus aus seiner sicht und sie
bekommt nur für dieses missbrauchs
kapitel bekommt sie eigentlich so eine
so eine stimme
und vielleicht kommt dadurch auch ein
bisschen was von dieser schieflage
zustande
das ist ja tatsächlich also da und das
ist auch eine sehr guten das ist eine
sehr genau wo woche bestimmt in der tat
ist da wen wendet dann wechselt der ton
und auf einmal spricht vanessa was sie
vorher in der form nicht so tut um aber
man weiß auch gleichzeitig genau ich
habe sie erzählt ihm dass und er erzählt
dann wieder mit ihr aus ihren augen so
zu oder schaut damit ihren augen auf
diese geschichte aber auf jeden fall
verändert sich der ton und dann ganz nah
an sie ran
und vielleicht wäre es wäre ja
vielleicht wenn er es früher angebahnt
hätte dass man stärker auch auf die
beziehung geben teilweise jedenfalls von
ihr aus ihrer perspektive schaut
vielleicht wäre das hätte dass das nicht
so unvermittelt gemacht und dann auch so
raus stechen
also das hat das stichjahr so raus und
dann wird es dann erst recht weil es
eben so wie du auch er meint ist ebenso
ein bisschen einfach konstruiert ist als
schaden schadens geschichte vielleicht
hätte das wenn wenn das eingeleitet
hätte anders hätte es anders gewirkt ja
ich kann ich also ich versuche gerade
interessanterweise so als der effekt
dieses gesprächs versuche ich ihn zu
verteidigen was er glaube ich überhaupt
nicht nötig hat obwohl ich das mit dem
problem ist problem schon genau erkennen
aber ich würde eben sagen auch durch das
gespräch und auch durch das was du eben
gesagt hast andrea mit der schönheit es
ist halt einfach in der der roman
handelt nicht von dieser
liebesgeschichte sondern handelt
abermals von diesen typen der von an
also und diese typen das fängt an schon
auch bei die zunge europas zweiter roman
da ist es immer so heiß und warum ist es
verdammt nochmal so heiß immer ist die
welt so ungerecht und so heißt zu mir
ich drehe hier weil durch immer schon
wieder ist es so heiß
die dies kann ich meine das so lustig
die müssen halt einfach alles um
eigentlich mehr oder weniger so kleine
kleine nullen die sich aber für
riesengroße zahlen halten es ist jetzt
aber metapher aber so
und leiden halt einfach so dass die welt
das nicht erkennt und so und dann aber
dann kommen sie auch nicht aus ihrer
haut draußen sind auch so mittelmäßig in
ihren interessen und alles ist einfach
desolat finde ich ganz gewiss das glück
es ist natürlich auch eine großartige
herausgehen anfangspunkt für komik
einfach ja also diese diese divergenz
zwischen ich fühle mich so groß aber ich
bin eigentlich so klein dass durch so
ein missverhältnis entsteht ja auch
einfach sehr viel komik aber dazu passt
dieses missbrauchs
dazu passt dieses missbrauchs klischee
ja dann doch eigentlich wiederum ganz
gut wenn man annimmt dass er darin eine
rechtfertigung findet dafür dass es
ihnen in dem augenblick in dem wieder
alle erwartungen die beiden doch ein
paar werden und auch also persönliche
gedanken intime gedanken teilen sich
näher kennenlernen
dass er dann eigentlich schon zu viel
hat dann ist das ja irgendwie sozusagen
ein gefundenes fressen um von sich
selbst absehen zu können als ursache
dafür dass es halt doch mal wieder nicht
klar
das ist ein interessanter also im also
wer mag nicht einstellen wollte
also wenn man sagt dass das klischee
dass entwickelt nicht strom oder dass
das ist dass das lassen wir nicht im
auto sondern das ist rettungsanker
dieser figur
das ist die rechtfertigung dieser figur
jetzt doch wieder was auszusetzen zu
haben oder für das was er auszusetzen
hat eine so einfache und naheliegende
unangenehm
und handhabbare erklärung
und das ist das ist ein interessanter
punkt weil nämlich daraus sich auch
quasi ergibt warum eigentlich diese
figuren so statisch sind also überall
sozusagen diese männer figur hat jetzt
über die verschiedenen romane hinweg
dass ich nicht also sind andere figuren
immer ihre grund konzentration auch wenn
manchmal ein bisschen anders ist als in
anderen büchern
er handelt sich stark und das ist
insofern statisch weil die nicht richtig
vom fleck kommen weil sie permanent mit
sich selbst hadernd reden und die
gegenwart beschimpfen und so weiter aber
sie aber die antwort darauf warum sie so
sind wie sie sind die die der kommen wir
keinen schritt weiter weil sie halt
einfach das ist auch eine bequeme
einrichtung in der welt sozusagen sich
bequem zurechtgelegt haben die welt ist
schuld die welt teilten die welt würfelt
mir immer nur irgendwie mittelmäßige
erlebnisse zu oder schwierige frauen und
so und irgendwie die eigentliche frage
ist ja obwohl diese typen so viel über
sich reden so richtig an ihr eigenes
geheimnis kommen sie damit doch echt nur
millimeter um millimeter näher und das
ist ja aber eigentlich ne total
faszinierend ist und deswegen da sind
wir wieder beim seriellen von dem was du
eben gerade sagt astrid ja mit jedem
schritt kommt man dann ein bisschen
näher dem der antwort auf die frage was
diese typen bloß jetzt für ein problem
haben und so und ja also quellen also
quälen aber gleichzeitig auch irgendwie
zum teil wirklich einfach auch dadurch
tolle tolle literatur also ich finde
eben die frühe von einigen von den
frühen büchern wirklich herausragend
eben in dieser art auch innovativ oder
auch sagen wir es fast schon pionierhaft
so eine figur solche figuren einfach zum
sprechen zu bringen aber ich bin auch
muss ich auch wirklich zu gestehen ich
bin also eigentlich von seinem humor
unsere studio braun soweit ich kenne
kaum als lustiger ist als das studio
braun das ist halt einfach wirklich
tatsächlich da bin ich so in andrea hat
das eingangs gesagt ich bin halt einfach
auch nur mittelalter norddeutscher mann
und findet das lustig
er hat ja wirklich tatsächlich einfach
eine riesige bandbreite also nicht nur
die bücher sondern die kolumnen sind das
auch gerade erschienen als sammelband
ist musiker komiker mit studio braun und
dann kommt natürlich diese ganze fractus
geschichte noch dazu die eben als film
dann auch im kino war also das ist schon
das ist schon echt ein kosmos ein strunk
kosmos der sich da auftut und wo man
auch tatsächlich glaube ich ich kenne
die studio braun sachen nicht so gut
aber da zieht sich doch wahrscheinlich
diese trostloser man sucht dinge auch
durch oder ist das da die ganze zeit
also auch das konnte auch in den aber
ich fange jetzt sofort an zu lachen weil
herr vorstellen was es da für lustige
das sind ja dann so telefonstreiche also
der film faktors ist dann noch mal was
anderes sind auch dann so praktisch ist
sie also die geschichte von einer pseudo
kraftwerk techno band die angeblich die
band gewesen ist den späten 70ern frühen
achtzigern die alt alles auf den weg
gebracht hat muss man einfach
kennst du nicht versucht liebe genau so
etwas halt thorsten waage und bernd wand
und wie heißt der dritte noch jedenfalls
sind so drei postens aus buxtehude oder
brunsbüttel ich bin mir nicht mehr so
genau was ich eben bei seinen eltern als
optiker geworden und so rund und sie
machen aber immer noch diese komische
kunst und heißt es einfach wirklich also
der abstand zwischen ambitionen der
eigenen dem eigenen größenwahn und der
wirklichkeit ist maximal hoch und
dadurch aber entsteht eine unglaubliche
komik und das ist wirklich da ich mache
jetzt die ganze zeit schon ohne wo wir
keine der voranden überhaupt ein feld
weil ich es einfach sollen die
grundstimmung ist schon sehr sehr
komisch einfach weil diese typen halt
einfach so trottel sind also
norddeutsche trotte ja ich habe gerade
letztens erst die folge von mord mit
aussicht gesehen ja hier auch eine
tragende rolle spielen also sehr sehr
gutes gibt es auch genau also mit dem
unvergesslichen satz da schießt rocko
schamoni und das ist das andere die sind
alle drei und strom gehört auch dazu
die wahrnehmung der sprache wie
gesprochen wird das haben alle drei von
studio braun also sagt preibisch
harmonie und strunk auch die sind sehr
sehr genau um zu hören wie heute
gesprochen wird und da gibt es so 213
genau an dieser mord mit aussicht folge
wo man das sehr genau hört wie ihr halt
einfach die auch das dann sprechen
danach sprechen können also das stimmen
immer ob man da war auf dem punkt wieder
zurückzukommen
das stimmt stimmenimitator ische im werk
von heinz strunk das nachmachen von von
von fürchterliches jargon egal ob er
jetzt nun aus der werbewelt oder aus dem
beton kommt das ist schon sehr sehr gut
und darin liegt ja nicht nur da ist das
etwas humor ist juristisch ist aber auch
eindeutig etwas aufklärerisches wir
sollten alle nicht mehr so sprechen das
sowieso nicht und wir sollten uns auch
nicht gefallen lassen dass so gesprochen
wird und ich glaube das ist das tief
moralische was da auch da drin steckt
nicht nur was da gibt es was ein
romantisches aber es gibt auch was
moralisches in diesem humor sie übrigens
an der titanic natürlich das ist ja
deswegen also das moralische hat ja auch
max goldt zum beispiel der ja auch immer
wieder so sprachmüll beiseite räumt und
so ja ja das stimmt und die und diese
frage ob der humor und das was vorher da
war ob der humorist da war und dann die
traurigkeit oder ob das ob er sich aus
einem humoristischen schriftsteller in
einen ernsten schriftsteller entwickelt
hat ich glaube das ist das ist das ist
da gibt es keine bewegung für ihn das
ist alles er ergibt das ist er von
anfang an gewesen und es gibt jetzt
nicht so eine entwicklung in dem sinne
dass er aus dem einen sich das sich aus
dem einen also der genauen
humoristischen gegenwarts durchdringung
das andere also das kritisch in
anführungsstrichen beschreiben der
gegenwart dass sich das so entwickelt
hat das ist alles von anfang an das
gleiche
besteck wasser hat und das hat ihn aber
deswegen bin ich so interessant jetzt
irgendeiner der rezension nicht aber es
war die zeit die dann versucht hat jetzt
eben diesen neuen roman mit honka zu
verknüpfen als wäre honka jetzt quasi so
der durchbruch ins literarische und das
ist jetzt quasi dass der eigene maßstab
den strom für sich selbst gesetzt hat an
dem man eben seine neuen romane messen
muss und das verkennt dann doch
tatsächlich die sachen die vorher da
waren die die die alle miteinander
zusammenhängen und eben quasi dieses
einzigartige diese einzigartige figur
heinz strunk das sage ich jetzt einfach
in dem sinne der ebenso viele
unterschiedliche dinge macht und alles
eben aber miteinander zu tun hat aber
separat trotzdem funktioniert das macht
diesen einen diesen einzigartigen figur
heinz strunk aus ich weiß gar nicht ob
er zur literatur gehört der gehört nur
so zu sich selbst also so ein bisschen
so wie helge schneider auch auf eine art
der ja auch sehr ernsthafter jazz ist
und wie man jetzt auch ja gemerkt hat
eben da auch keinen spaß versteht wenn
er seinen job nicht machen kann und dann
auch von der bühne geht
wenn ich das sieht ja ich habe also ich
hab ich habe halt so eine privat theorie
dass eigentlich menschen die das
komische besteck wirklich beherrschen
dass die einfach die besseren romane
schreiben aber vielleicht schreiben sie
auch einfach nur die die mir irgendwie
mehr geben aber da gibt es ja
tatsächlich sehr sehr viele beispiel
also auch buchberg zum beispiel hat bei
der lesebühne angefangen ja und der hat
der hat eine art von komik und
schlagfertigkeit die sehr viele andere
schriftsteller einfach nicht haben und
der weisheit genau wie man die wirkung
erzielt und wie die pointen sitzen und
wie die sätze knallen und ich glaube das
haben einfach komiker was ist was vielen
anderen schriftstellern so ein bisschen
ab geht und auch dadurch auch ich glaube
man wenn man leute zum lachen bringen
will will man auch einen effekt haben
und ich glaube das ist dann diese
unterhaltung dass man eben auch nicht
langweilen will das bringt ist auch
schon eine ganz gute einstellung um
romane zu schreiben einfach mal das und
publikum unterhalten finde ich erst mal
per se sehr begrüßen
sich das ja ich hatte jetzt auch thomas
mann sonst halten können aber ich der
ist ja auch komisch der kleine aber ich
wollte jetzt das jetzt einfach so die
faz filtern standard-antwort zu sagen ja
auch thomas mann aber es gilt natürlich
genauso auch für thomas mann der sehr
lustig lustige figuren erfunden hat die
lustige dinge tun und so dass da merkt
man dass auch also aber das wollte ich
eigentlich jetzt habe ich doch getan
entschuldigung für zeitliche reflex aber
sagt man wir haben jetzt etwas auf dem
tisch liegen wir haben einen film wir
haben kolumnen die note die romane im
unterschiedlichster zurichtung damals
geschätzten kommen noch dazu
danke was was haben wir noch vergessen
music studio braun
denn was von oder wenn nun in dieses
werk von heinz strunk einsteigen möchte
wo steigt er am besten ein wo fängt man
am besten an andrea du musst sagen also
mein einstieg persönlich war junge
rettet freund aus teig und das war kein
schlechter einstieg es war vielleicht
nicht der typische einstieg weil das
sehr viel von dem strom kosmos so nicht
hat weil es eben an einen jugendlichen
etwa sind ganz jungen erzähler hat weil
es eben eine melancholische geschichte
ist und eine freundschafts
familiengeschichte aber ich fand den
einstieg tatsächlich nicht schlecht aber
ich glaube man ist mit fleisch ist mein
gemüse zum beispiel auch gut bedient
würde ich mich das wäre jetzt einfach
ganz das wäre jetzt wirklich auch meine
antwort weil da eigentlich im grunde
alles schon da ist was sich dann anders
was sich dann anders in anderen büchern
zeigt und es ist einfach eine
unglaubliche lustiges buch und auch eine
innovatives buch weil diese welt ja da
beschreibt diese hochzeitskapelle ich
komme auch aus norddeutschland vom
flachen land wo halt einfach sonntags
man weiß da gibt es da diese kneipen wo
dann am abend vorher große feste
gefeiert wurden und dann so die die die
schnapsleichen noch am nächsten morgen
einer theke sitzen und dann gibt's halt
immer diese band die fürchterliche
fürchterliche versionen vom lemon tree
spielen müssen uns unter das ist ja dann
seine welt
und es ist gleichzeitig das ist
gleichzeitig witzig aber es hat auch
einen ganz ernsten kern weil im grunde
diese themen die man jetzt auch zb hat
im neuen roman und judith hermann also
was ist eigentlich im land los das land
trocknet aus was diese landschaften
sterben aus die städte werden größer
aber die sozusagen diese zwischenräume
landschaft quasi dorf und so
verschwinden
das ist da alles schon drin und das
erkennt man besonders gut wenn man also
der der strom card zusammengearbeitet
eben auch mit dem lars jessen dem dem
regisseur der frack tus gedreht hat der
aber auch eben rocko schamoni zb eine
fantastische dokumentation gerät hat
über das sterben der landgasthof in
schleswig holstein und man sieht daran
dass eine ist natürlich dass diese welt
skurril und seltsamen tritt damit diese
mit dieser komischen kapelle auf und das
publikum ist immer besoffen und keiner
welt zahlen und so aber gleichzeitig ist
das eben auch das fundament der
bundesrepublik aufnahmen auf einem
niveau das ist eine
mentalitätsgeschichte auch und solch ein
riesen riesen antwort gegeben hier aber
dass ich würde ihm auch sagen da gibt es
einen sehr sehr ernsten kern und ging
und den der auch jetzt bis ins neuesten
buch da ist der aber auch wenn man
fleisch ist mein gemüse als lustigen
roman lesen oder buch ist wer würde man
wahrscheinlich heute sagen gibt es dann
ernsten kern zu sagen hier das ist
bundesrepublikanische
mentalitätsgeschichte ohne dass es dran
steht sondern steht eben dieser wahn
sich lustige titel dran und das wäre
mein einstieg
das stimmt also bundesrepublik kriegt
man da wenn auch die er die nördliche
hälfte der bundesrepublik aber dass das
ist auf jeden fall da drin und dann eben
auf seine auf so eine finstere art und
weise also brd noah ist ja so ein
schlagwort was immer wieder mal
auftaucht und das ist halt tatsächlich
genau dass dieses etwas muffige dieses
pfiffige diese diese schützenfeste diese
grauenvolle perversion von auch
popkultur die da ab gefeiert wird also
ja ja das ist auf jeden fall auch so ein
schlagwort für heinz strunks männer
liegt er sofort heimatgefühl das ganze
ja
[Musik]
du sagst es durchaus mit etwas wehmut in
der stimme
ja ja ist so sind sind wir jetzt
eigentlich gerade ganz weit weg von es
ist immer so schön mit dir oder sind wir
noch ziemlich nah dran
naja ich meine es gibt diesen diese
romantik hotel in dem eben diese jetzt
auch schon angriffe szene spielt mit dem
mit der mit der mutter dem rücken von
mir geburtstag der mutter
da ist man schon wieder auch sehr nah
dran also da ist man wirklich wieder so
in dieser dieser falschen vorstellung
von rom gemütlichkeit falsche
vorstellung von familie falsches gerede
über die gegenwart und alle sollen sich
aber zusammenreißen und jetzt mal gute
laune haben um es jetzt mal ganz platt
zu sagen dass dieses element ist er auch
drin ja also wenn sie ja wir sind
eigentlich nicht weit weg glaube ich
dass das romantik hotel ist ja für ihn
auch so ein inbegriff und ich kriege ja
oft von hotels tatsächlich pr mails
romantik wochenenden mit candle light
dinner mit duftkerzen mit partners
ölmassage also es sind immer wieder
eigentlich die gleichen ingredienzien
die ich eben für so eine zweisamkeit
stehen die aber natürlich total
äußerlich und durch kommerzialisiert
sind und also wenn man mal drei von
diesen von diesen pr mails von möglichen
romantikhotels gelesen hat dann kennt
man das arsenal das da auf gefahren wird
und so war es zum beispiel habe ich
bisher noch nicht so oft beschrieben
gesehen dass ist schon wieder sehr
strunk aber auch eben diese falsche
vorstellung von oder dieser diese das
missbrauchte wort romantik in dem
zusammenhang gehabt das ist dann auch in
die aber mich wie gesagt mich haben die
mich hat diese passage etwas ratlos
gelassen weil halt einfach darauf einmal
so rum randaliert wird
und da sowieso ein battle die schwester
der von von vanessa und eben der
hauptfigur sich ebenso vorgestanzte
setzte an kopf hauen und ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich weiß nicht wo ich also
verlässt der roman quasi seine handlung
wird zum sprachkritischen
feuerwerk falscher ausdruck wird wird
auf einmal so 'ne sprach kritisch
reingeschoben episode die überhaupt
keine die die überhaupt also quasi keine
richtige szene mehr ist und das könnte
man jetzt sagen es ist jetzt so quasi
exponenten aus der handlung heraustreten
so bleibt auch immer noch drin irgendwie
so dass man weiß wo man ist aber ist
einfach so seitenweise werden da halt
einfach dann so so motivationssprüche
aneinander gehäkelt und da hat mich dann
doch wirklich das fand das fand ich also
beim andrea balderi sie gesagt hast eben
das fand ich lese weil ich dachte okay
aber dass du musst das auch das ist zeit
also stimmt ja an wieso vom sprachgefühl
aber du musst es dann auch erzählen weil
das du musst einfach erzählen warum das
jetzt ja auf einmal so abgesondert wird
fand ich ein bisschen ja wenig das
stimmt die abkürzung können wird dir
jetzt gerade mal nicht lieber autor so
ja ja das stimmt so enden wie auf einer
kritischen note eines sturms roman ist
es immer so schön mit dir ist es gerade
im rowohlt verlag erschienen und kostet
vielen vielen dank liebe tobias ich
danke euch das hat viel spaß gemacht
dankeschön unsere drei fragen zum
schreiben und zum lesen haben wir
diesmal der schriftstellerin daniela
krien gestellt ihr letzter roman hieß
die liebe im ernstfall ist aus dem
frühjahr 2009 10 und dem einen oder
anderen bestimmt noch in guter
erinnerung mir zumindest schon auch in
der brand gerade erst erschienen geht es
um eine liebe im ernstfall um einen
sommerurlaub in dem ein paar fast 30
jahre lang verheiratet zwei kinder damit
klar zu kommen versucht dass ich die
liebe aus ihrer ehe verabschiedet hat
die erste frage die ich daniela krien
gestellt habe warum sie schreibt ach ja
das ist eine frage die ich für mich auch
nur nachträglich interpretierend
beantworten kann
also ich schreibe so lange wie ich wie
ich lesen und schreiben kann
und damals als ich ein kind war habe ich
da glaube ich nicht wirklich über das
warum nachgedacht jetzt rückblickend
würde ich sagen dass das es von anfang
an eine bewältigung war mit der
wirklichkeit sozusagen umzugehen mit
meiner zum teil schwierigen wirklichkeit
bin aufgewachsenen kleinen dorf mit zwei
eltern die nicht sehr glücklich
miteinander waren dem abwesenden vater
und mit freunden die meine leidenschaft
nicht geteilt haben also ich war so das
einzige kind im dorf das intensiv
gelesen hat ich könnte mich da nicht
wirklich austauschen und ja war oft
recht einsam und ich glaube dass daher
umso meine meine einsamkeit zu
bewältigen und um mein leben zu
strukturieren das schreiben dann
begonnen hat am anfang war es natürlich
sehr autobiografisch
ich habe ganz viel tagebuch geschrieben
und ja und daraus wurde dann immer mehr
und mittlerweile ordne ich beim
schreiben für mich auch meine
wahrnehmung der welt in der ich liebe
gar nicht mehr so sehr meine privaten
dinge sondern tatsächlich mich in bezug
zur gesellschaft oder die
gesellschaftlichen vorgänger die ich
beobachte die versuche ich in den
büchern
irgendwie auf den punkt zu bekommen und
geordnet kriegen das ist interessant
dass sie sagen diese bewältigung stand
schon im allerersten schreiben im
vordergrund ich hatte mir genauso gut
vorstellen können das ist so ein
eskapistische schreiben wäre so dass
geschichten in denen alles ganz anders
ist dann im mittelpunkt dieses
schreibens stehen
ja das gab es auch aber erst später der
anfang war wirklich also diese diese
frühen tagebücher oder gedichte ich habe
am anfang ganz viele schrecklich
kitschige gedichte geschrieben
da ging es schon immer irgendwie um
meine eltern und die situation da in
diesem dorf und mein mein unglück in das
ich mich sehr hineinsteigern konnte
damals als kind und die einsamkeit also
einsamkeit weil man großes thema ja gab
es die idee der mitteilung in diesem
schreiben oder ging es darum etwas
loszuwerden etwas festzuhalten war das
gedacht für leserinnen und leser oder
nur für sich selbst in dem moment die
also die ganzen ersten jahre des
schreibens
die dass das war extrem privat und intim
tatsächlich so so intim dass ich auch
die tagebücher später berichtet habe als
ich so anfang 20 war habe ich mir das
alles noch mal durchgelesen und habe das
alles weg gewonnen eingeweicht in wasser
in eine plastiktüte damit auch wirklich
niemand mehr lesen kann weil es zum teil
extrem emotional gewesen ist natürlich
sehr kindlich und in der zeit der
pubertät völlig überzogen auch das waren
wirklich bewältigungsstrategien das war
für niemanden gedacht außer für mich
selbst wie ist es heute wäre es heute
ihr erster leser oder ihre erste leserin
und wie kritisch darf er oder sie seien
meine erste leserin ist meine lektorin
tatsächlich die bekommt den text
meistens schon in einer fassung mit
einer frühen fassung wo ganz klar ist
dass da noch viel arbeit zu tun ist und
und sie muss sehr kritisch sein also ich
bitte sie darum sehr kritisch zu sein
denn es hilft mir überhaupt nicht denn
wenn der lobhudelei kommt und ich am
ende ein buch veröffentliche das
irgendwelche fehler enthält und
peinlichkeiten aber ich bin ich bitte
immer darum dass das wirkliche über
strenger blick auf den text gerichtet
wird
und wenn sie das einmal durchgegangen
ist und ich noch mal überarbeitet habe
oder ein zweites und drittes mal
überarbeitet dann bekommt es mein
lebensgefährte zu lesen und es ist mein
härtester kritiker überhaupt
also das sind sitzungen mit ihm zusammen
am text vor denen ich schon lange vorher
schon angst habe er findet wirklich der
findet alles also überhaupt ich jetzt
mal ich hoffe am ende deines er sagt
jeder jede logische ungereimtheit auf
und
ja ich bin ihm sehr dankbar dafür aber
spaß macht das nicht ja und gerade wenn
es auch um emotionale ungereimtheiten
geht wie viel in ihren büchern ist das
wirklich schwierig aufzudecken finde ich
ja das stimmt mich wundert dass ihre
lektoren eine frühe fassung bekommt und
dann kriegt ihr dann hart kritisieren
darf also ich würd ich will also ich
kann mich da nur rein versetzen ich
würde ja eigentlich immer schauen dass
ich eine möglichst stabile fassung schon
um nicht zu viel kritik abzubekommen
eine möglichst stabile fassung schon das
erste mal los schicke also wenn der der
text noch nicht so weit gediehen ist
schon in der rohfassung muss natürlich
stehen
das grobe konzept muss da sein und die
dramaturgie das muss alles stimmen die
figuren müssen klar sein aber dann gibt
es den moment wo man die lektoren
tatsächlich nochmal
grundsätzliche fragen in der regel sind
wirklich nur fragen es ist nicht so dass
sie dann sagt da und da musst du etwas
ändern sondern sich sie schreibt mir
fragen dazu und anhand dieser fragen
beginne ich meine figuren nochmal besser
zu verstehen und manchmal eben auch
handlungen zu ändern das ist das ist für
mich wirklich hilfreich da relativ früh
im zweiten blick drauf zu haben weil ich
sonst mich in meinem tunnel befinde und
manches einfach nicht mehr sehe
sie waren das einzige kind im dorf das
gerne und begeistert gelesen hat sagen
sie welches buch würden sie von heute
aus rückblickend ihren jüngeren oder
einem ihrer vielen jüngeren ich
empfehlen was hätten sie gern früher
gelesen gehabt als kind als jugendliche
als junge frau als kind habe ich glaube
ich alles wichtige gewesen selbst kind
gelesen haben sollte als junge sei ja da
hat meine mutter zum glück auch sehr
darauf geachtet aber als junger oder der
jungen frau würde ich einige bücher
geben die ich erst spät entdeckt habe
also nicht zu spät aber die mir
vielleicht im leben weiter geholfen
hätten hätte ich sie ihr gekannt das
sind gar nicht so sehr effektive bücher
so keine romane sondern vor allem
autobiografische bücher oder sachbücher
also zuallererst fällt mir einen von
viktor frankl trotzdem ja zum leben
sagen
das ist ein buch das was mir unglaublich
geholfen hat alle möglichen
schicksalsschläge zu bewältigen und das
hätte ich gerne schon eher gehabt und
dann auch ein paar autobiographische
schriften die mich enorm inspiriert
haben mit zum beispiel von joachim fest
ich nicht oder von hans graf von
lehndorff das ostpreußische tagebuch das
sind alles bücher die ich dich immer
wieder lese und eigentlich alt bücher
die ich mehrfach lesen würde ich meinen
jüngeren ich empfehlen weil es gut
ja genau genau weil man in verschiedenen
lebensphasen dass ich ganz verschiedene
dinge ausliest
und und ich immer sehr hilfreich finde
also autobiografisches schreiben finde
ich bei anderen sehr spannend weil ich
mir da sehr viel rausziehen kann das ist
nicht also mein weg ist das nicht ich
würde sowas nicht schreiben wollen und
vielleicht auch gar nicht können aber
ich ließ das wahnsinnig gerne
vielen dank liebe frau krimis war ein
toller antworten ja vielen dank
im september und im oktober ist daniela
krien mit ihrem roman auf lesereise und
wer will kann sie zb in leipzig hamburg
halle an der saale in jener münchen
tübingen oder in berlin erleben
besprechungen einiger bücher von heinz
strunk und dann jeder green finden sie
wie immer als links in den schoß und auf
unserer seite
faz.net / büchern in das podcast mm wie
sie müssen dort finden sie auf die
adresse unter der sie uns erreichen
können bücher - podcast faz.de sie
wissen ja auch wie sie uns leiten oder
abonnieren oder sternchen geben können
oder herzchen oder was auch immer gerade
der pott catcher ihres vertrauens
bereithält
das wissen sie hoffentlich auch und zwar
weil spotify auf instagram auf apple
podcasts und so weiter und auf instagram
heißen wir etwas bücher in einem wort
mit für diesmal sagen wir vielen dank
fürs zuhören und bis bald
bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]